the key to becoming an efficient
programmer is to never write any bugs
unfortunately that's virtually
impossible when your code doesn't work
as expected 99 of the time it's your own
code to blame you cannot blame all me
however about 0.99 of the time it's the
pulse of somebody else on your team and
you can get pissed off at them
accordingly
but the other .0099 of the time it's a
bug in some shady Library you downloaded
from npm which means you'll have to open
up an issue on its GitHub repo or fix it
yourself and open a pull request or just
build your own new library from scratch
however the other point zero zero zero
zero nine nine percent of the time it's
the programming language or compiler
itself to blame in which case you'll
need to get in touch with some people
much smarter than yourself who determine
it's not a bug with a compiler but it's
an edge case that happens
.00099 of the time and the actual
Hardware is to blame like one transistor
was placed just a few nanometers to the
left and that's why your website doesn't
look quite right on a Blackberry but the
hardware people say it's not their fault
it's actually just an edge case that
happens point zero zero zero zero zero
zero one percent of the time where your
code is just not compatible with the
laws of quantum superposition due to a
defect in the simulation in which we
live in other words it's God's will that
thou code shall not work luckily bugs
like this are pretty rare and in today's
video we'll look at seven universal
debugging tips that every developer
should be familiar with the first tip is
to read that may seem stupidly obvious
but programmers want to get things done
quickly and tend to be overconfident in
their understanding of what the hell the
computer is actually doing what will
often happen is you'll guess what a
method or function is doing based on its
name but remember there are only two
hard problems in computer science naming
things and coming up with new original
jokes for YouTube tutorials like there
might be a function called get random
number you automatically think it's
always going to return a different
number but when you call it it returns
three every time it's not a bug because
had you read the documentation you know
that 3 is a random number that was
chosen by the developer in advance who
guaranteed that it was 100 random when
he chose it with the roll of a die
reading documentation in advance is
important but developers also tend to
skip right over error messages when
first learning to code you get these big
cryptic error messages that seem totally
overwhelming so instead of reading it
you just try to change up your code
until the message goes away that might
work sometimes but you'd be much better
off learning how to understand the error
messages and go through a stack Trace
because that will eliminate the
guesswork now most of the time even
after you read the error you'll still
have no idea what it's talking about
luckily there's a very powerful tool
that can help you translate it called
Google but when it comes to error
messages you don't want to just paste
the entire error message with the full
stack Trace into Google Googling as a
software engineer is an art form you'll
want to First parse the error and remove
anything that's unique to your actual
project Google is pretty good at
ignoring things that are unnecessary but
the more you can do to point it in the
right direction the better if the
keywords on the air are pretty generic
you might also want to add the name of
your language or framework to the
beginning just to limit the number of
results I couldn't imagine living
without Google and stack Overflow but at
some point you'll hit a wall and have to
do some good old-fashioned honest
programming the easiest way to approach
debugging is with logging where you
simply print out different pieces of
data from your application to manually
verify that it's running as expected
it's not very sophisticated but it works
a JavaScript beginner might use console
log to print out every single variable
but your logger probably has more tricks
up its sleeve like JavaScript has
console count to keep a running counter
in your code or timer to measure time
and table to format things in a more
user-friendly way you can also log at
different levels like info warning and
error to organize the priority of this
data and use console dir to display it
as a hierarchy the bottom line is that
logging is a perfectly acceptable way to
debug and you should take some time to
learn the full API of a logger in your
language to maximize its efficacy the
problem with logging though is that it
gets harder and harder to do as your
code grows larger and more complex
luckily modern Ides and editors have
tools that can help you observe and
execute your code at scale these tools
are called debuggers and there's one
integrated directly into vs code it
allows you to Traverse through frames in
the coal stack which means you can
pinpoint the exact moment a bug occurs
it's possible to pause the execution of
your code at any time using a debugger
statement or better yet you can use the
IDE to set up breakpoints that don't
require any modifications to the actual
code in addition it eliminates the need
to pollute your code with console logs
everywhere because instead you can just
add log points by clicking next to the
line of code that you want to log so
basically a debugger is just a more
sophisticated way to run and inspect
your code eventually you'll find a bug
that you just cannot fix when that
happens it can sometimes help to not
focus on a solution but figure out a way
to reproduce the problem with a minimal
amount of code like start an entirely
new project where the only goal is to
make this problem happen and bonus
points if you can reproduce it somewhere
like stack Blitz where anyone can run it
instantly in a browser creating a
reproduction has several benefits one
there's a good chance you'll solve the
problem when going through it and two if
you don't find the root problem you now
have an example that you can share with
better programmers if you can't reliably
reproduce a problem it's nearly
impossible for anyone else to help you
out unfortunately not every bug can be
reproduced which is called a Heisenberg
there's a great story about the Crash
Bandicoot video game where the load say
feature would work perfectly almost
every time but every once in a while it
would time out and wipe out the entire
memory card after six weeks of trying to
debug this one issue they were
eventually able to reproduce it by
wiggling the PS1 controller a certain
way to corrupt the memory card it was
one of those rare cases where the
hardware was at fault another very
common type of bug that is very
frustrating is one that happens after
your code was working perfectly before
this is called a regression which means
you wrote some new code that [ __ ]
something up at a certain point it
becomes impossible for a human to verify
that everything works properly after
every code change and that's where
automated testing comes in or test
driven Development I've made many videos
in the past about testing but the
general idea is that you write code to
make sure that your other code is
working as expected most importantly it
gives you the confidence that you're not
introducing new bugs when you make
changes but it can also help in the
debugging process when you encounter a
bug instead of trying to fix it right
away you can go straight to writing a
test this forces you to be explicit
about what you're actually trying to
make the code do and in the process
you'll likely learn things about your
code that you didn't understand
previously and finally after you get the
test to pass you'll be protected from
reintroducing the same bug another way
to catch bugs before they become a
problem is to use a tool that performs
some type of static analysis on your
code in the case of JavaScript the most
common way to do that is to use
typescript which adds an entire type
system on top of the language which may
makes it far more difficult to introduce
stupid bugs like using the wrong
variable name somewhere or assigning the
wrong data type because the typescript
compiler won't even let you run your
code when you make mistakes like this
the drawback is that typescript can be a
pretty big investment and you may not
want to add it to your code base in that
case consider adding eslint by itself to
your project it also performs static
analysis and attempts to improve your
code quality and requires very little
effort on your part that gives us seven
different ways to debug code but I have
one more bonus tip for you which is to
turn off your computer and take a break
if I had a dollar for every time I was
fighting a bug then went and took a
break and came back and immediately
solved it I would have a shitload of
dollars I like to go outside get some
exercise and bask in the Sun and enjoy a
smooth and flavorful Marlboro cigarette
Marlboro may surprise you it's the
filter cigarette with the unfiltered
taste on second thought you may want to
skip the cigarette unless your goal is
to die a horrible agonizing death and if
you go to hell the only programming
language they have down there is Java
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one